this video is sponsored by tiege Hanley
athleticism isn't just for athletes it's
my belief that more people should focus
on improving their athletic performance
rather than just exercising to get a
little bit stronger or to lose weight
exercise so that you can run faster jump
higher become more explosive improve
your endurance and get stronger if you
do this it's going to have far greater
transfer to nearly every aspect of your
life you'll be better at sports you'll
be more impressive at moving home you'll
be less likely to injure yourself and
you'll have far more energy throughout
the day you'll gain more physical
Freedom more options to do more things
so with that in mind I thought I'd share
some of my favorite exercises for
boosting athleticism
so first of all is the banded lateral
walk now what we're going to be doing
here is placing a resistance band around
the legs and we're going to be stepping
out sideways in each Direction This is
obviously going to train the hip
abductors the ones that move your legs
apart from one another and this is
important because not only does it
improve stabilization not only does it
improve your cutting ability to change
direction quickly but it's also actually
going to improve your hip rotation and
this is important because when you get
up out of a deep squat for example
you're actually using hip rotation
external rotation in this case to drive
yourself upwards as well as just flexing
the legs next up is the barbell hip
Thruster invented by Brett Contreras who
very kindly appeared in my last Batman
training video so the idea behind this
exercise is basically like a glute
bridge but you're going to be suspending
yourself so that your upper body is
higher up and placing a barbell across
your lap then you're just going to be
driving up through the hips in order to
raise that weight off the ground
because when you run of course you need
to generate power from your glute with
your leg in this extended position
driving off of the ground whereas
exercises are like squats for example
they train the glutes in this really
nice deep position and when you stood up
but they don't go into a fully shortened
position which is where you need to
generate that power so exercises like
the glute Bridge or the hip thrust which
lets you add the extra weight and gain
extra range of motion can be really
beneficial in that way so many of us
fail to activate our glutes at all
because we spend so long sitting and
this means they're weak and it's much
harder to engage them the glutes however
should be your primary anti-gravity
muscles and exercises like the hip
Thruster like the glute Bridge they'll
train you to engage the glutes actually
use them when you should be using them
to tap into more of your latent athletic
performance
by the way guys how am I looking today
beautiful right yes well if so that
would be thanks to tiege Hanley sponsors
of today's video tiege Hanley is a
company that provides skin care products
for men this is a big deal for me at the
moment as I've noticed little sunspots
appearing likely due to all the time I
spend training Outdoors what's great
about teach is that it really simplifies
the process of skin care you get a
regular box containing a range of
products and instructions on how and
when to use each one if you start with
their level 1 System you'll get all the
basics a daily face wash a twice weekly
exfoliating scrub an evening moisturizer
and a morning moisturizer with SPF 20 to
help keep your face protected that's
what I'm most excited for and it's great
having that peace of mind this is the
sort of thing like exercise we're
investing a little time and effort now
could make a huge difference to the way
you look and feel a few years down the
line members get 20 off their retail
price the ability to customize their
boxes exclusive deals each month and the
ability to pause or cancel at any time
shipping is free in the US and low cost
around most other countries they have
over 5 000 5 Star reviews so they must
be doing something right and because
tiege Hanley is sponsoring today's video
they're offering my viewers a great deal
just click the first link in the
description and you'll get 30 off your
first box plus a free gift seriously
that's an amazing deal click that link
and get started today
thanks again to tiege Hanley and on with
the show
so of course based on my recent track
record I wasn't going to make a whole
video about athletic exercises without
mentioning Ben Patrick needs over toes
guy and one of his favorite exercises is
the atg split Squat and here's another
one who was very kindly willing to share
with me a video for my Batman training
program in that he described that the
atg split squat is great for targeting
the VMO the vastus medialis which is the
quad muscle with the highest density of
fast twitch fiber at the same time it
was also really interesting is they
explained how by stretching the hip
flexors which are so often tight because
of the way we tend to sit all day on our
butts we actually can improve the
engagement of our glutes and this makes
a lot of sense when you think about that
position even when you're running again
where you're pushing off your back foot
this requires a decent stretch on the
hip flexors so if they're really tight
you can't Engage The glutes to the
maximum and this is going to result in
poorer athletic performance so there's a
wonderful Synergy here if we combine the
hit thrusters with the atg split squat
we can actually tap into even more of
that power that we already have and then
by training these will get stronger we
can gain even further abilities still
I've come to a different location to
film this one because it's a little bit
weird and out there but it is one of the
most bang for your buck exercises I
think you can do especially when it
comes to athletic performance it ties
together so much in particular in a
recent interview JC Santana was telling
me how ankle stiffness is what he sees
as the biggest missing piece of the
puzzle when it comes to sprinting speed
in particular because if you don't have
ankle stiffness then you're going to
dorsiflex as you push off of the ground
with your foot and this is going to
waste a whole lot of energy as he put it
you can have the fastest strongest legs
in the world but if you run on Sand it
makes a huge difference he recommends
doing the car push for this which is a
fantastic exercise and my only issue
with it is that it's quite hard to
recreate if you aren't training with a
partner and don't have a big parking lot
to practice in something you can train
that will give you the same kind of
angle the same kind of ankle stiffness
is a bear crawl with added resistance
now this could be a sled or as I've
hacked and used in the past it could be
a sandbag which I've actually attached
to bands now they very sure that these
aren't going to snap or come loose and
come hit you in the face but if you can
be sure of this then what I call the bag
drag is a fantastic exercise it's also
going to strengthen your quads and your
glutes and your hamstrings and it's
going to generally make you a much more
powerful athlete it's fantastic cardio
and it involves both a pull and a push
because you're pulling yourself forwards
on your hands and you're pushing
yourself to keep yourself in that
upright position and it's a
quadrilateral movement it's a cross body
movement so you're building those
important athletic patterns and moving
in the correct way really great for
proprioception
so another really great move for
building athleticism and in particular
explosiveness is the snatch and really
any of the Olympic lifts is going to get
you there these build real fast twitch
muscle fiber they're also highly
technical lifts that require a lot of
technique and a lot of training you
don't want to just launch straight into
this however a slightly easier and more
versatile variation that we can use
wherever we are is the sandbag snatch
with a sandbag you still have to have
that basic strength and structure and
don't do this if you have any issues
with your back or with your elbows or
your wrists or your shoulder however if
you're feeling a little bit confident
this is something you can do in your
garden because the sandbag isn't that
expensive you can even make your own and
it's also something that's not going to
hurt you as much if you get it wrong
there's loads of evidence that people
who do Olympic lifting can jump super
high run really fast because in many
ways these lifts are like jumps they're
launching the weight into the end then
getting underneath it it's really
explosive and that's the kind of
explosiveness we want if we want to
boost our athleticism
one of the best tools out there for
improving athletic performance is the
medicine ball and there's two exercises
in particular I want to talk about right
now the first is the med ball slam
simply grab it like so
slam it down making sure to keep the
core relatively straight you're
generating power from the hip flexors
from the lats you're compressing your
body so that it's the reverse of a
triple extension essentially it's a
triple compression this means that
you're training the antagonist muscles
thereby giving yourself more control
through that movement pattern this also
transfer to the deadlift at the same
time it also means that you can get
quickly down into that counter movement
in order to launch and spring yourself
back up for a high jump
and the other exercise I want to talk
about is the rotational throw so you're
taking the medicine ball into a kind of
shot put position you can also hold it
in two hands like this and then what
you're going to do is generate power
from your core by rotating you want to
rotate at the core itself but also the
hips driving through the legs like so
if you do it against the tree or a wall
then you can bounce it back and use it
as a form of conditioning as well the
reason this is so powerful is because of
course athleticism isn't just about
building strength and power in your legs
you also need the powerful and explosive
upper body and when it comes to that
rotation is King whether you're throwing
a javelin or a shot put whether you're
throwing a punch whether you're hitting
a ball with a racket or a bat you need
to rotate your core and drive power that
way so one of the very best exercises
for building athletic performance
particularly running speed according to
the research is the Nordic curl I almost
didn't show you this because I'm so bad
at it and also it's a move that's really
hard to train I really want to get a lot
better and this really outlines how weak
my hamstrings currently are I'm using a
hack that I learned watching these ever
toes Guy where you stick your feet
underneath your own car it's one of the
only things that's heavy enough to not
topple over when you're doing this but I
mean I don't even have a drive in my
house this is embarrassing even for me
so yeah I need to figure out a way I can
do this at home because this trains your
hamstring through a full range of motion
and it's been demonstrated to translate
to faster running speed so really it's
awesome and you can really feel it
working of course another fantastic one
is the single leg RDL not only are you
training the hip hinge movement not only
are you training and stretching the
hamstrings but at the same time you're
also training stability on that
supporting leg as you lean forwards and
this of course is really important as
you need stability on a single leg when
you're running when you're jumping after
running it's just a really important
really valuable movement
so if you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that'll
help me out immensely let me know in the
comments down below what some of your
favorite athletic movements are that
perhaps I've left off of this list this
is by no means a comprehensive list I've
left out loads I just wanted to present
a few that I found really useful lately
and particularly because some of them
have this great Synergy together that I
really wanted to share with you guys if
you like this kind of training that
looks not only at Aesthetics basic
strength but also at performance in
terms of running speed jumping height
Mobility endurance even brain function
and focus then you might enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 that comes with a video
course that's over two hours of video
tutorial as well as an 80 plus page
ebook and it goes into depth and all
this stuff and it provides a complete
program that anyone can follow designed
to adapt to any level and all kinds of
different equipment if that sounds
interesting then please check it out on
the link down below either way thank you
so much for watching this one guys I
hugely appreciate it and I'll see you
next time bye for now
foreign